la parole est à madame marie laure
phinéra horth pour le groupe e
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant merci
madame un présidente madame la ministre
cheikh khaled construire plus et mieux
tel était l'un des objectifs de la loi
portant évolution du logement de
l'aménagement et du numérique dite loi
élan promulguée en 2018 c'est un
objectif que vous poursuivez dans le
contexte actuel que nous connaissons et
particulièrement dans le logement social
en effet le 2 février dernier vous avez
fixé madame la ministre un nouvel
objectif à l'ensemble des acteurs les
partenaires sociaux comme action
logement
la caisse des dépôts les organismes hlm
et les collectivités territoriales aussi
avec le soutien financier de l'état à
hauteur d'un milliard 5 250 mille
logements sociaux pourraient être
construits dans les deux ans à venir
si nous pouvons nous satisfaire de cet
objectif ambitieux mon interrogation se
porte sur la part de logements sociaux
prévus en outre-mer comme vous le savez
ces territoires font face à des besoins
grandissants liés aux flux migratoires
aux mutations culturelles telles que la
préférence pour l'habitat individuel au
phénomène de la décohabitation à la
prévenance de la précarité et surtout à
une forte demande de logement social
exacerbé par la crise sanitaire avec 80%
des ménages d'outre-mer éligibles au
logement social contre 66 % dans
l'hexagone et près de 70 % d'entre eux
situés sous les plafonds de ressources
ouvrant droit à des logements très
sociaux contre 29 % dans l'hexagone
aussi madame la ministre sur les 250
mille logements sociaux que vous
prévoyez de construire quelle sera la
part accordée aux territoires
ultramarins qui font également face à
une pénurie de logements sociaux
je vous remercie madame la ministre vous
avez la parole merci madame la
présidente madame la sénatrice sorte
vous avez rappelé les particularités des
territoires ultramarins qui justifie
l'engagement de politique en matière de
foncier et d'habitat adapté aux enjeux
propres de chacun de ces territoires et
je voudrais commencer par saluer le
choix de la délégation aux autres
maire de mettre le logement au coeur de
son programme de travail pour 2021
l'état s'engage et accompagne
particulièrement les territoires
d'outre-mer sur ces questions de
logement et d'aménagement je souligne
ainsi la création récente des
établissements publics fonciers et
d'aménagement de guyane et de mayotte
avec pour priorité de produire des
terrains aménagés nécessaires au
développement de l'offre de logements et
d'équipements dans ces territoires ont
besoin de façon urgente la production et
la réhabilitation de logements sociaux
sont financés par la ligne budgétaire
unique sur le programme 123 du ministère
des outre mer qui finance en gros 10
mille logements par an logements sociaux
mais aussi des logements neufs de
l'accession sociale
malgré la crise la consommation de cette
ligne qui a atteint 218 millions en 2020
est en augmentation de 30 millions par
rapport à 2010 9 et pour 2021 les
crédits sont de nouveau en est haute à
plus de 240 millions une dynamique
importante a donc pu être maintenue en
2020 alors même que le niveau d'agrément
reconnaissait une chute en métropole il
faut bien sûr viser à maintenir cette
dynamique en 2021 2022
les 5000 à 6000 logements sociaux qui
sont financés chaque année dans les dom
s'inscriront dans le cadre de ce de
l'objectif de 250000 que nous avons
fixés comme vous le savez ces objectifs
quantitatifs précis sont donnés
territoire par territoire dans le cadre
des plans de logement outre-mer
le plan d'investissement volontaires
d'action logement qui prévoit un
milliard cinq consacrés au logement en
outre mer s'inscrit dans cette
territorialisation au delà donc de
l'objectif global de production de
logements sociaux en outre mer qui doit
être aussi ambitieux qu'en métropole
il est nécessaire de poursuivre et de
préciser ce travail de
territorialisation et avec mon collègue
sébastien lecornu nous y serons
particulièrement attaché merci madame
phinéra horth vous avez 48 secondes
merci mme la présidente je remercie
madame la ministre pour sa réponse
simplement la population guyanaise en
tout cas attend beaucoup de ce projet de
logement lorsqu'on sait que bien souvent
ce sont les occupants illégaux lors de
la démolition de squat à qui en attribue
ces logements sociaux qui sont
disponibles alors merci beaucoup